the first of these was divination well
we know what would be about divination
because especially taro divination but
also others have been somewhat revived
since the 1960s but what is divination
you might see it's fortune-telling
trying to figure out by way of some
cards or doing some coins or something
of that sort as to what is going to
happen that is not divination divination
which was of course very important part
of life in the ancient world among the
Greeks and the Romans and so forth
literally meant consulting the
divinities for advice now I don't know
whether you believe in divinities or
whether that makes much sense after most
of us come from a monotheistic
background but let's say the issue is
that there are powers whatever we may
wish to call them in the universe and
perhaps in the deep regions of ourselves
and these powers are both capable and
not only willing but eager to give us
guidance in the perplexities and
difficulties of our lives if we learn
how to avail ourselves of such guidance
our life and our consciousness is
thereby considerably enriched that is
the whole essence of divination it is
not really and primarily what is going
to happen in the future and so one
begins to look for the signs of guidance
and these signs have often been
organized into particular modalities
like the ancient Romans for instance who
learned a lot from booth on the
Etruscans and from the Greeks and all of
us were full of divinatory methods
whatever they looked at they could use
for divination the flight of the birds
the flowing of the water everything
under the
but let's say in the Golden Dawn they
used to a great extent the tarot cards
which were almost unknown at the time
the Golden Dawn were the people who the
first people who really brought into use
among Western peoples the Chinese Oracle
de Jing or Yi King the Book of Changes
Jo Mansi which is a much simpler form of
divination and of course also astrology
why did they advise the use of these
things in order to refine the
sensitivity the magical imagination of
the person someone who becomes affinity
stoever the creative use of a divinatory
modality will have developed a
sensitivity to work the imaginal world
and the imaginal world is not imaginary
in the sense of non-existence but rather
it consists of images the images of
various realities which are in that
great intermediate area between
ourselves and ultimate reality another
preliminary exercise that the Golden
Dawn